cuando john lasseter creó su
cortometraje animado quería una lámpara
joven observó que los niños tienden a
tener cabezas y traseros más grandes en
comparación con el resto de sus cuerpos
de manera que para hacer que su lámpara
pareciera más joven y así poder crear al
juniors redujo la escala de la lámpara
completa y luego aumentó la escala de su
pie y su cabeza para obtener algo de
experiencia en la creación de nuevos
modelos agreguemos algunos de formadores
de escala para modificar la lámpara en
pixel el departamento de arte a menudo
nos da dibujos superpuestos para
guiarnos en la remodelación del
personaje en el siguiente ejercicio
veremos un dibujo superpuesto como este
que intentarán igualar usando de
formadores de escala cuando hayas
terminado tu lámpara debe verse mucho
más joven